Let's have a look inside the
token classification pipeline.
In the pipeline video, we looked at the
different applications the Transformers
library supports out of the box, one of them being
token classification, for instance predicting for
each word in a sentence whether they correspond
to a person, an organization or a location.
We can even group together the tokens
corresponding to the same entity,
for instance all the tokens that formed
the word Sylvain here, or Hugging and Face.
The token classification pipeline works the same
way as the text classification pipeline we studied
in a previous video. There are three steps: the
tokenization, the model, and the post processing.
The first two steps are identical to the text
classification pipeline, except we use an auto
token classification model instead of a sequence
classification one. We tokenize our text then feed
it to the model. Instead of getting one number
for each possible label for the whole sentence,
we get one number for each of the possible 9
labels for every token in the sentence, here 19.
Like all the other models of the Transformers
library, our model outputs logits,
which we turn into predictions by using a SoftMax.
We also get the predicted label for each token by
taking the maximum prediction (since the softmax
function preserves the order, we could have
done it on the logits if we had no need of the
predictions). The model config contains the label
mapping in its id2label field. Using it, we can
map every token to its corresponding label. The
label O correspond to "no entity", which is why we
didn't see it in our results in the first slide.
On top of the label and the probability,
those results included the start and end
character in the sentence. We will need to use the
offset mapping of the tokenizer to get those (look
at the video linked below if you don't know about
them already). Then, looping through each token
that has a label distinct from O, we can build the
list of results we got with our first pipeline.
The last step is to group together tokens
that correspond to the same entity.This
is why we had two labels for each type
of entity: I-PER and B-PER for instance.
It allows us to know if a token is in
the same entity as the previous one.()
Note that there are two ways of
labelling used for token classification,
one (in pink here) uses the B-PER label at the
beginning of each new entity, but the other
(in blue) only uses it to separate two adjacent
entities of the same type. In both cases, we can
flag a new entity each time we see a new label
appearing (either with the I or B prefix) then
take all the following tokens labelled the same,
with an I-flag. This, coupled with the offset
mapping to get the start and end characters allows
us to get the span of texts for each entity.